[Applaudissements]
dorian ces trois semaines pendant six
heures non-stop je vais parler aux
spectateurs donc il faut pas perdre la
voix
c'est des réveils en général vers 6h 7h
du matin maximum classé incroyable il ya
toutes les caravanes publicitaires donc
c'est génial c'est le moment un peu où
on rencontre du monde on prépare bien
sûr nos véhicules donc ça c'est quand
même le plus important moi en tant
qu'animatrice du coup voilà je vais bien
installé mon micro faire des essais son
volume et cetera bien-être accroché un
harnais quand même s'il faut savoir
qu'on est sur le tour voilà c'est des
routes quand même de montagne sera donc
on est quand même libre donc faut être
bien accroché
[Applaudissements]
nous on est en avant en amour descoings
et on fait du coup tout le parcours moi
mon rôle ça va être justement de parler
de tout et twist dire aux spectateurs
que les caravanes arrive qu'on va
distribuer j'ai un micro toute la
journée je vais m'adresser à aux
spectateurs donc il ya toujours une
petite pression par rapport à ça après
voilà moi du coup je vais représenter
tourtel twist j'ai rencontré justement
les directeurs et qui sont vraiment très
sympa donc l'ambiance générale fait que
ça détend forcément aussi
[Musique]
ça me croyable les gens ils sont super
contents d'être là moi je dis que je
rencontre des personnes même dans la vie
de tous les jours je leur dis que je
fais le tour de france ils sont super
contents ils disent tous ça mais nous on
a hâte on a découvert le parcours on
sera sur telle route
le tourmalet l'étape du tourmalet c'est
franchement c'est plein la vue à chaque
fois qu'on y va du coup j'ai fait deux
en deux ans on y aller c'est très commun
comme parcours c'est magnifique
franchement du départ à huy la montée du
col c'est incroyable s'est plaint lève
vraiment je conseille à tous les leaders
[Applaudissements]